and we've got someone in the studio now
who might have an answer
Claudia comfort of the German Institute
for Economic Research the DI W in Berlin
it's good to have you with us so let me
pass on this question for how much
longer do you think will the price of
oil continue to head south this is very
difficult to say because it's primarily
expectations who drive the price at the
moment because from the fundamental
market data we see we have an oversupply
of oil and also a declining demand but
that's not new we know this since many
months but right now the expectations of
speculation drives the price so it's
very difficult to say whether it will go
down again or will go up which would
also be a an opportunity yeah but what
seems to be really surprising is that or
producing countries like Saudi Arabia
for example so far haven't throttled
production because that of course would
be a tool to boost the price of oil
again yeah but they will not do it
because there's a geopolitical Crowl
role here between Saudi Arabia between
OPEC and the USA because USA produces a
lot of oil at the moment with fracking
unconventional oil and this needs the
price of oil which is above 80 or $90
per barrel and right now the price goes
down and the OPEC countries hope that
the USA will decline their production so
I don't think that the OPEC will react
at the moment what stay in the United
States for a while and fracking because
it's it's not that unproblematic really
a lot of the companies involved in
fracking are deep in the red and now in
addition the price of oil is falling and
some experts already warned that this
could trigger a new credit crunch yeah
we receive what will happen but what is
true is that they need a higher oil
price than we see at the moment so it
might happen that the oil production
will go down in the US and some
companies of course will also collapse
but we receive what's happening on the
other world in the OPEC countries what
they will do how much they will produce
because this depends also on what's
happening in the USA for how much longer
do you think the OPEC countries can cope
financially
economically with falling oil prices it
depends on the OPEC country you look at
Venezuela for example needs a higher
price right now Russia as well but Saudi
Arabia can cope for a longer time so
they are quite different in in OPEC and
we will see how they will react and what
will happen in the future a consumers of
course are thrilled about cheap oil but
environmentally both fracking and of
course the use of oil is not exactly
helpful to fight climate change so yeah
we need a high our price for fighting
climate change of course but we will
need also other policies like energy
saving away from fossil fuels renewable
energy and all this and Europe and China
and also a little bit of USA are going
this way so the climate policy is one
question but the oil now is another one
what we know is that oil is and this and
we need we need more I mean we need
alternatives and that's what we what we
have to go that's also interesting you
say we know that oil fossil fuels aren't
endless yes and yet the price keeps
falling normally that's not the case no
especially if we see this geopolitical
difficulties in the world so you see
that this is the oil prices driven now
by expectations by speculation this is
not fundamental market data which drives
the price primarily at the moment but we
will see and what what the market actors
expect and this is why we can take now
really see whether the price will go up
and go down so bottom line in one
sentence the cheap price of oil the low
price of oil good or bad for the economy
well it depends on where you look at
because for some industrial nations is
good because it helps the economy for
others who export oil is bad because
they need high income all right two
sides to the coin as usual Claudia kinfe
thank you very much thank you